promised tracker is a mobile data
collection tool that allows citizens to
track the status of government promises
related to issues they care about
citizens can create an issue based data
collection campaign and recruit other
community members to join their
monitoring efforts as part of the
promise tracker web tool citizens can
customize their own mobile data
collection forms and deploy them on
Android phones to inform our design we
conducted several workshops in Brazil
this year one workshop was in Sao Paulo
and another was in a favela in Belo
Horizonte during the workshops
participants identified issues they
wanted to monitor in their community and
discuss which of these issues the
government was responsible for improving
based on the chosen issues we customized
an Android data collection app and
participants walked their community
streets collecting data and discussing
issues with their neighbors participants
collected data on a number of topics
they cared about including
transportation trash collection
accessibility and housing demolition
participants created data presentations
from the data during the workshops
we also created interactive maps of the
data they collected to host the photo
and video stories they collected data
collected and mapped using premise
tracker can be used for variety of civic
scenarios such as lobbying the
government for a specific infrastructure
improvement or rally one's communities
to fix a local problem we are currently
using the insights from our workshops in
Brazil to inform the design of promise
tracker which we will continue to
prototype and test over the coming
months